but this is this is why this is why
earlier I bought in history and the fact
that
there was a point where women we weren't
even allowed in education so in terms of
financially men have already had their
head star that's why I would say that
okay women they tend to be homeless
because men have had the Head Start From
that's why I'm saying our generation is
going to change things a lot because in
terms of women are going to be able to
catch up a lot more
so women are going to be able to catch
up a lot more
um yeah I feel like we can't ignore
history when it comes to find when
you're considering Financial the
financial position of men and women you
can't ignore history I just get totally
sick of that
you know when it comes to like the
finances because I've worked in jobs and
I've earned the same as the men
and when they talk about all this pay
Gap and that the men have had it and the
women have had it as far as I'm
concerned there's no reason why a woman
can't go out there and get paid the same
money for is she saying qualified same
qualified same qualifications same job
same experience I've done it
I've done it and I've also got a pay
rise every year I've never ever worked I
had a man on the same role as me same
experience earn more than me so when
they and you're talking about the old
generation I'm the old generation but
what I'm trying to say here is this what
sector is this transport Management in
transport okay and it doesn't matter
where it is because wherever you go you
can get paid you're required to have a
certain level of qualification any job
you can go any job that a man can get
qualified at and get paid a woman who is
equally qualified equally experienced
and has the same manner when it comes to
working because that's what we've let
women down they're mannerisms when they
go in they're either going like oh you
know they're going too strong but if you
go in the job with the right frame of
mind and nowadays the women are more
qualified
from in my generation that's what you're
going to say the women are more
qualified in the old generation we
weren't that qualified and the Young
Generation they were qualified now so
there is no reason for people to say oh
but the men have got it now because
they've earned more that's rubbish
nowadays well especially for the new
generation because it's there for you on
the plate you've got it better than us
yeah so I don't understand like what
does that have to do with me today that
like some women were locked out of
Education before I was born how does
that affect me because even in these
environments let's say a woman has
managed to get to let's say a very
senior position it's still an
environment that is dominated by male
nurse especially white smallness so for
instance if you're a white woman and
you've now come into this space you have
to overcome the barrier of being a woman
in a male dominated space no I don't
okay so how would you how would you
adapt do you want cards you work hard
like that's what I said like every time
someone Billings their pay on the pay
Gap they're lazy honestly they're lazy
because the pay Gap doesn't exist when
you take in this is where you don't
understand when you take into account
personality differences between men and
women women don't ask for raises that's
the problem sixty percent of women have
never asked for a raise and you're going
to complain that you don't get paid the
same you don't ask for a raise that's
why I'm saying the environment a man
because this is an environment that men
have been in no it's a choice it's a
choice before women if I personally me
personally I would ask for a raise but
it's it's different because the it takes
confidence to ask for that confidence in
yourself and if you're in an environment
that wasn't even made for people like
you people like you for some women there
will be some of the there will be some
of the first people in that kind of
environment and they have to thrive in
that you have to overcome the barrier of
having to adapt in that environment
that's something a man doesn't have to
do when there are quotas okay so there
are specific quotas to give women jobs
over men men don't have any quotas so
working they don't need it no no because
why why do they why do we need a quote
or do you not think women are qualified
to get the job on their own I didn't say
that no but that's what you're implying
by saying no no no no no no that's why I
said you can't ignore the history no
because the reason the question that's
an excuse that's an excuse I'm not
saying it's an excuse okay anyone can go
out and get any job they want nothing's
stopping us there's no law stopping us
and if anything there's incentives I
mean I've worked in a male dominate the
environment all my life
I
was the only
black woman supervisor black woman
manager
props and it never props to me it was a
job I didn't care whether I was black or
not I'm getting the money I'm getting
the same one as everybody else to me it
didn't matter whether I was black or not
it was a job and the men who got the job
I've got the job they earned the same as
me and every year I make sure I got my
pay rise the way they did and you didn't
and I had the same age you didn't make
it no and the thing is and the thing is
with women I find that when they go out
like yes you're actually that's a change
I'm in a male environment I'm with a
loaded meals so yeah you know I mean I
can hold my own I can have a
conversation I'm going to dress feminine
but I'm going to start my own like
masculine but you see when I step out
the house and I get home to my man all
feminine oh submissive and that's what
the women fail to realize now that the
new generation because you can go out
there and you can do a job just as good
as a man and when you come home you
forget that you're a woman you're still
going like you're a man that's what the
men don't like I'm I didn't I did
everything curious insinuated I did it
I'm not insinuating I'm just saying I'm
speaking from experience because I don't
want to hear the excuse of oh because
you're a woman you've got to go in that
environment and act a certain way
rubbish because of your color rubbish
because of your sex rubbish because of
the pay rubbish because I've done it and
it's the norm I've done it so all we
need to do if you want to get paid more
the same way how you can speak up and
say oh my woman this and that speaker
must say excuse me but I'm doing pay
your eyes can I have my money this is
how hard I've worked this is what I
deserve and this is what my contract
says now that's what I'm saying that now
you can do that but it hasn't always
been like that no I'm older than you I'm
53 I'm retired so you can't say now you
can do that because I've been doing it
okay but you can't this is what I mean
you can't ignore the history okay but
before I'm history I'm I'm the history I
am the history are you ignoring history
I am 53 I am retired I am your history
so you can't tell me to forget about the
history
and before my history
if you're talking about the top sectors
because they're still for instance in if
you're talking about science if you're
talking about tech if you're talking
about engineering these sectors there's
still a lack of women why because the
women don't go and do it if there's a
lack of women go and do it I wanted to
be a bus driver there was lack of women
you know what I've done I didn't
complain said there's no women bus
drivers go and do it they didn't have no
managers go and do it don't sit back
complaining that in these top sectors
nowadays you've got all the
qualifications you the young people you
can go University you can get degrees go
and do it you know what I mean women if
you want to do something but don't
complain about it change it like like
you said women are doing it but the
results are still not the same yeah
really they're not doing nothing
women are the most educated but they
don't make more money because they have
a ton of debt and women don't make the
majority of workplace deaths where's the
equality where are the marches men are
the majority of workplace deaths they do
all of the hard jobs therefore they get
more money do you want to be a plumber
do you want to be a bricklayer the only
the only jobs you're seeing are the the
two percent of jobs like CEOs power
power positions hypothetically but my
dad was one of those top one percent
CEOs he worked 80 hours a week for 40
years do you want to do that I don't
most women don't they want to have kids
okay that's again that's why I said this
is you can't you can't mix the two
because you're saying women should focus
with what you're saying you're saying
women should focus on having kids and
for that reason they wouldn't be able to
do that 80 hours a week no I'm not
saying what women should and shouldn't
do I'm saying I don't like excuses no
because you are you're blaming you're
blaming the pay gap on being a woman I'm
not blaming them you're saying you're
saying we need to be aware you're saying
you're saying we need to be aware of our
history I'm saying that has nothing to
do with me today I was born in 2022.
there's nothing that is holding me back
as a woman if anything it's offered me
advantages because all the men hiring
are attracted to you no I that's you you
apply for a job you're a pretty young
girl most men that hire you are going to
be attracted to you good to be young I
guess I'll do it all again
do you not believe that oh to be young
again no no it's true it's true and the
thing is you you was talking about
history and that uh men had a head start
it's been that way since the dawn of
time and it's only recent that we've
come into this this time and and that
the outcomes are terrible this is the
first time we're changing it you know
I'm a boss lady I'm making money I'm
getting the bag and look 50 of women are
by themselves one in four women are and
and uh one in four women are on
antidepressants and on top of that how
can we say we were disadvantaged before
when we didn't have to fight in Wars
the men were the ones that had to go
fight in words we'll say my body my
choice all day but we'll never talk
about their body their choice when they
get drafted women the majority of women
didn't even want the right to vote
because it came with the responsibility
of getting drafted so most girls are
like I'm a chill in the kitchen and I
absolutely would chill in the kitchen if
that was the same thing today that's the
mindset that that's the mindset that she
had again I wouldn't say that the
mindset that I have is the mindset of
the majority but again like I said you
can't use that to you can't use that to
just dismiss what has happened like he
said he said men he said that men have
had their head start and it's been like
that since the dawn of time but now that
times are changing you guys are still
you are still placing the value of women
on fertility and in the sexual
Marketplace I did not say personal value
I said in the sexual Marketplace okay so
the men the fact you mentioned that a
man had to do 80 hours a week why can't
a woman do that then that's what I'm
asking a woman can they choose not to
I'm telling you like I I watched my dad
work his whole I didn't know my dad
really until I was older I barely saw
him and I I most women would not sign up
for that they can't keep lawyers at
high-end law firms past like the age of
35 because they say screw this I have
all the money I want all I want now is a
family
they can't pay these women to stay
because after a certain age your looks
are starting to go you're what are you
doing this for after you make a certain
amount of money so again the thing
that's limiting women is well based off
what you just said their personal
choices and I don't think it's limiting
women
I don't so if there's nothing stopping
us from doing anything today and more
women say hey I would rather stay home
or take a lower paying job that I like
instead of doing the shitty job that all
the men are doing why is that a bad
thing
you can't say personal choice because a
man doesn't have to make that choice yes
he does that's my point a man can make a
choice of do I want to go into education
which pays less or do I want to be a
plumber that pays more you mentioned at
35 women go off and that's when they go
and start their family a man could have
had a family up until that point he
doesn't have to make that choice that's
what I'm saying no he can he can be a
stay-at-home Dad if he wants to but you
can't get rid of our biological Roots he
can also make that choice he could go
get a sugar mama if I mean certain men
not everyone has that not all guys can
pull that off but but you see what I'm
saying he could he could do a 50 50
relationship there's nothing stopping us
from making these choices it's just
women don't want to work hard jobs
men do
as many women have got more choices now
and they're just using their excuses
they've got more choices than ever
they're more powerful than ever they've
got more rights more everything than
what I had in the past but what are the
outcomes
they're more unhappier than ever right
yeah one in four women are on
antidepressants women owned two-thirds
of the debt even though they make less
money 70 to 80 percent of consumer
decisions are made by women married
women are more likely to be divorced
three years after their promotion to CEO
levels compared to their male
counterparts and the divorce men 70 to
80 percent of the time
again like I said I don't think the
mindset that I have is the mindset of
the majority of women but again you
can't dismiss the things that are the
things that are um limiting women from
getting to that point you can't dismiss
it what is limiting Us in 2022 if I've
gone and I've had a child if I was okay
let's say for instance I was in the
middle of my degree and I've had a child
I'm not in the same position as a man at
all did you just to have the child
okay what about the state so I
abortionately is not illegal okay that's
incorrect
it's not illegal in the U.S no I said
what about the states the states states
in general I'm not talking about the
United States I'm talking about States
in general no I'm saying I'm saying in
the United States abortion is not
illegal you get a car and drive to
another state we're spoken about the
United States I'm talking about States
in general I'm talking about the world
in general I feel like a lot of what
we're saying and a lot of what we're
discussing is focusing on the developed
world it's ignoring because we're in the
west that's we're talking about the West
okay but I don't think we could we
should ignore the reality of so many
women but I'm saying you're moving the
goal post because we were discussing the
west and now you're saying well what
about what about the not the west but
we're talking okay sorry I'll talk about
women I'm talking about women
generically generically because when
you're bringing when you're talking
about the debt you're talking about all
of those things that's women in the west
and those are the choices they're making
so would you agree there's nothing
holding back women in the west there's
nothing oppressing US History doesn't
matter we're all born today nothing
we're cool nothing to complain about
I would say we're not as limited as
people in the developing world that's
what I would say